[Music]
siggy ron hillmarsson is an icelandic
baker
with an unconventional oven
he bakes bread by burying it underground
where it's heated for 24 hours by nearby
hot springs it's very common to see hot
springs here in iceland there is
constant lava crawling under us
this lava is heating up water and this
water comes boiling up on the surface
we could put it in the oven but this is
much more fun
iceland is one of the most volcanic
regions in the world with 30 active
volcanoes at any one time
that helps create an abundance of hot
springs
some with boiling hot water
and siggy uses them to his advantage
he specializes in baking hoove abroad a
traditional icelandic rye bread recipe
that dates back hundreds of years
i know for sure that in this village
i can track it down
as far as late 1800s something
my grandmother taught my mother how to
bake this bread
and my mother taught me
in the hot spring rye bread recipe we
have rye flour sugar baking powder salt
and milk we put this in a pot we put
butter in the pot then we wrap it with
plastic foil and we put it down in our
hot spring hole for 24 hours
it's very obvious to see if the ground
is hot or not i never use a thermometer
if i need to check the heat i just use
this one
our biggest challenge is rain
if it rains a lot these holes that we
are using can cool down
and if they are not hot enough obviously
the bread doesn't bake completely
[Music]
everybody eats our bread our visitors
the locals hot spring rye bread has a
unique taste that you don't get from
ovens
the texture of this bread is quite
special it's quite heavy it's not the
typical light bread
when you show this to travelers that
come to iceland and you see their faces
they go wow
then you start to think that this is
quite amazing actually
you